Speaker 2: Okay, remember that if you'd like
to get on your nickname in the waiting lobby
on discord needs to be name and location
of where you're calling from. It doesn't
even have to be real, but it has to be name
and location. Otherwise you are not going
to be eligible to participate today.
Let's go to Carl from Bremerton. Carl,
welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 6: How's it going, David? It's going so
pretty much what I wanted to say was, should
I feel like I shouldn't be? But should I be
celebrating the like win of Tim Ryan against J.D.
Vance in the line of the year? And that's getting
a lot of traction and whatnot, even though I
find him much less liberal than I like. But I
understand it's because he's in Ohio. Yeah.
And he has to kind of walk that weird line
where he's got to get the indecisive Trump voters.
Speaker 2: But let me address that a little bit.
But what was the line of the year? I watched
the debate. What was the line of the year?
Speaker 6: It was that we need a kicker, not
an ass kisser, like, oh, okay. Yeah, yeah. And
here's the thing. Yeah, it was a good line. Like,
I remember being like, wow, like I was watching
it when you watch it. And I reacted the same way.
Speaker 2: I like Tim Ryan as a person. He's been
on the show and I've had a couple of conversations
with him off air, like before we did an interview.
I to be honest, I don't know Tim Ryan's real
politics. And what I mean by that is at one
point he seemed quite a bit more progressive to me
than the way he's running right now. I understand
the dynamics of Ohio may impact how he's running.
He's been critical on issues related to the border
of Kamala Harris and Biden and all these other
things. I think that as a practical matter,
J.D. Vance is such a dangerous disaster that
like, you just got to vote for Tim Ryan. If you
live in Ohio, it's obviously the right decision.
But without a doubt, the way he's running now,
it's well to my right that's for damn sure.
Speaker 6: Mm. Yeah. And I mean that's pretty
much how I felt was like, hey this, I'm glad that
this is like because this seems like, I feel like
if I was an indecisive like voter that was like,
maybe think of voting for Trump. If I saw that,
yeah. And actually looked into it, they'd be like,
Wow, he is like, awful. I should definitely vote
for that guy. But for me, I'm from Washington,
right? So like, I'm pretty liberal anyway. So
when I see that and then I hear him talking
about how you agree with Trump, I'm like.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't think on the tariffs.
Speaker 2: And saying.
Speaker 6: No, I don't think that's something
I would be like happy about know. Like then
I'm like, you know, he's in Ohio, so I get
it. Yeah. That's why I'm saying what to do.
Speaker 2: Or overwhelmingly the better option.
And also, if he was a presidential candidate,
I'd say you sound almost like a Republican.
Speaker 6: Yeah. 100%. Yeah.
Speaker 2: All right, Karl, thank
you for the call. Appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Thank you, man. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: All right. That's a big race. So
I hope all of our Ohio voters will indeed be a
voting and that one, it is extremely, extremely
important. Let's go next to Lucian from England.
Lucian, welcome to the show. What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hello? Me?
Speaker 2:
Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Oh. Okay. Thanks for picking.
First of all, how much are you keeping up
with the economic and political situation
in the UK? What's your general take on it?
Speaker 2: Only a little bit. If I understand
correctly, it seems there are significant
economic concerns in the UK. Liz Truss
initially planned a tax cut for the rich, which
correct me if I'm wrong. She has since abandoned
because in the context of what's going on,
it seemed like a disastrously bad idea.
Speaker 4: Yes, that's right.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And then I saw
an economic prediction that the U.K.
could have some serious hurt in front
of it as well. No, I don't know that I have
any particular opinion. I mean, I think the
I when I read the headlines about specifically
what's predicted in the UK economically,
I wonder whether it's really just going to be part
of a bigger economic shift in the US and Western
Europe. Like I'm not fully understanding
why this would be isolated to the UK.
Speaker 4: That's what I was going
to ask, is to what extent some of
the same issues present in the USA as well?
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I mean, our economies
are so tied together and dependent upon many
of the same interests and industries, many of
the same trade relationships. Obviously, our our
stock markets don't move in lockstep necessarily.
But it seems strange to see some sky is falling
predictions for the UK and then some predictions
in the US that after December 2023 should actually
look pretty good. It seems hard to imagine that
there would be such a stark difference.
Speaker 4: We'll see what happens. I think
the interest rate question is probably the most
pressing right now. It's pretty dire here, I would
say, in terms of interest rates, I'd say. Me and
my partner just bought a house two or three months
ago. We managed to complete that. If we were to
have done it now, instead we would be paying 50%
more per month on our mortgage. Basically, what.
Speaker 2: Are mortgage rates in the UK?
Speaker 4: When we got it was about two
and a half percent, I believe. Now it's
gone up to 6%. Oh, so similar here.
Speaker 2: It's similar to here. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a big difference. Good
thing you bought one. You did, I guess.
Speaker 4: Very, very lucky. Just another
really quick question. You said you got some
heritage from Eastern Europe, right?
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean,
almost exclusively.
Speaker 4: Have you have
you actually been there? No.
Speaker 2: I have not.
Speaker 4: If you'd. If you'd be interested, I'd
be quite curious to know what you think about the
culture and everything. I'm from there initially.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I mean, so one of the things is
my family being all Jews from Eastern Europe,
they, you know, spoke a different language and
sort of were were relatively concentrated in
certain communities due to some unfortunate
realities at the time. And so, you know,
I think that by and large, the culture in
which my ancestors lived primarily have sort of
eroded in Eastern Europe. You know, Ukraine and
Russia and Belarus. So I don't even know that I
could really I could go and see what the culture
is like now. I don't think I would have the
experience of seeing what was the culture that
my ancestors lived in, because it's mostly gone.
Speaker 4: Right. I understand that. That's
really, really unfortunate. Yeah. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much.
Speaker 2: For the call. Thank you. Thank you.
All right. Let's take a very quick break. If
you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones in a moment.